[Music]
alright this famed French serial killer
expert hua has recently confessed that
his prestigious career has been founded
on lies he's a liar so you can study
fake serial killers
No so he has exaggerated his expertise
mr. Momo
I know serial killers myself and how can
you get certified in serial killer nests
he claims that his own wife was murdered
back in 1976 in Los Angeles but in
reality he never he wasn't married she's
in the other room actually I don't know
if he was expert he started with his
wife getting murdered yeah so this is
where like the beginning of his like
yeah I got motivated what a great
catalyst yeah so my wife got murder
cited up happening though was the woman
who was actually killed was in night
this happened in 1975 this 25 24 year
old woman was murdered by a serial
killer who was who the serial killer
later admitted to killing 41 women and
was executed in 1998 so this woman was a
bartender who he this this guy he had
met her about four or five times or four
or five or six times when she was a
bartender but he's French but this was
in the 70s unlike this is when he was in
the United States and so it was an
online relationship they didn't have
that back then they did it this is 1975
when she got killed so that's when and
this was in in Florida so he changed the
location he changed the relationship to
use a year all that stuff right so he
said that he took he said it was
[ __ ] that I took on I didn't want
people to know my real the real identity
of someone who was not my partner but
someone who I had met five or six times
in Daytona Beach who I like she had a
relationship with her in his mind
well like he needed to feel like this
traumatic event happened to him so this
is
the reason why he got so like infatuated
with serial killers cuz then from then
on he started researching them and he
has even he has claimed to have
interviewed more than 70 serial killers
but in reality it seems to be about ten
exaggerator there's something wrong the
funny thing is there's nothing wrong
with just being inspired by a story
there's nothing wrong with like hey man
I want to study serial killers and I
study ten that's already remarkable it
is I feel like if you've had a personal
experience you should not do it like if
your wife died you should not be a
you're too emotionally involved but it
makes for a good story motivation most
people they become doctors because a
family member got sick like it's really
normal me where would Batman be if his
parents didn't get [ __ ] up by Joker's
homies the author could have wrote
something else completely different
where's Iron Man he was so rich so
[ __ ] rich wait I don't know I just
made Matt Murdock he was rich his
parents were rich okay for those
thinking about Bruce Wayne so this dude
he also lied about being trained at the
FBI base in Virginia big time liar man
he also lied about interviewing Charles
Manson Oh this wall ended up being an
author of more than 40 books yeah did he
even write it himself though it's kind
of good writer
booth actually for it turns out that
it's only one book actually he had
actually taken a lot of stories and a
lot of like serial killer motivations
whatever from American literature and
stuff like Melton he just copied and
pasted other [ __ ] people things
pretty much he plagiarized yeah please
your eyes and he rewrote those things in
French because he was like a super
prestigious like French serial killer
expert did he catch anyone so they were
saying that um they're actually really
shocked because he he was like spot-on
on some cases like he predicted certain
movements of this particular serial
killer he is an expert study that's so
much of a shitty backstory which he
didn't need to do pretty much how did
this we'll get caught recently there was
this like this
anonymous collective called forth I who
had uploaded a series of videos on
YouTube accusing him of lying and that's
when quickly the story became like a
sensation in France and they started
like really digging into all these
claims and accusations and then that's
when he just came up and said like yeah
I'm fraud why do they
but if he's doing good why do they not
go after people like if you say you they
think Trump's doing bad why don't they
go after Trump and trial probably one of
his peers as jealous as [ __ ] wait so who
caught oh I like the name cuz they're
like the third eye sees more but the
fourth I see is really more nose
basically but for like checking people
sources I don't know if their focus on
any other people it just mentions that
this is the anonymous like we catch a
[ __ ] that started accusing him because
they started seeing how there were there
was a lot of inconsistencies and dates
that he would mention like of his past
experience with certain lines interviews
of [ __ ] serial killers there wasn't
consistencies with like the way he would
like the way he would conduct his like
expertise like it was just inconsistent
it was who did he go to
oh no he only are like for real I don't
know but he claimed to be trained at the
FBI the foot by and nobody even checked
at the foot by cuz if I was at the pho
by right and I was reading this [ __ ] I'm
like I love this guy man he's the reason
why I joined the for by but he's in
France I was like a bomb killers and how
the FBI VC term that term oh yeah what
was it mean show the show that it's like
David Fincher oh it's like old right
like it was like a timepiece in the
sixties or some [ __ ] right yeah yeah
yeah oh like my friend my French Manson
are like friends with Vincent no no this
was about serial killers I know when
they first discovered this phenomenon
because no such thing has happened in
the past in the US and they didn't even
know how to identify what this was you
guys see now I feel you have seen it
I can't watch her like that well another
outrageous claim that this dude did it
or said is that he worked as a
professional footballer Oh bro just
[ __ ] stop you [ __ ] pathological
liar yeah I'm assuming it's soccer
footballer and then there I go that's
how these guys make the great novelists
and what he should have stayed in was
like fiction or like he could have made
a religion but was he hurting anyone by
life I don't know I guess like the
principle of it all is like if you're
gonna be claiming to be an expert like
you should have the credentials to back
it up but yeah because this guy could
have been like Stephen King he could
have been stephen king of like horror i
mean a serial killer books or whatever
it's like those guys who like steal a
lot of money and but they already made
too much money before that you know he
just didn't know where to stop his lives
he just kept going could've got away
with it cuz he was already successful
but something he kept picking up yeah
he's been in the scene since like the
90s is like when he really started
getting really funny you know what make
me more interesting because he's
actually a serial liar yeah I think what
he likes to do is he probably likes
trying to get away with stuff so he's
just saying like I possibly is he still
care he's looking around to see if
anyone catches on oh really
he likes that attention I mean yeah he
wants to come up with more [ __ ] and more
[ __ ] like the guy that I thinks he knows
everything
oh you know about like who this guy is
and they're like oh who's that under
like oh he's a scientist so yeah I know
I know she's probably like that's the
probably all you hear what Todd's my
singles who's that he goes özkaynak yeah
yeah I interviewed them yeah one of my
favorite things to do is catch a lie and
push them to go further and further
while other people will call them off
out on that and I like to watch them lie
more and more and more I like that there
was that technique that was in that
commercial for like massive class where
you just like listen yeah and then they
just stopped by real FBI agent yeah you
watch the actual one it's good how long
is it how long is it uh I don't remember
I think it's like 10 episodes or
something do you use a hiker or
Isaac Isaac no you ladies you it would
have been great for you all mafia I know
right
would it help him off you the things you
learned in there because the whole point
of it all like is to let the other
person give you the information that's
the whole like basis of it and like it's
just these techniques to get the other
person to spill because everyone wants
to talk everyone wants to talk about
themselves in particular - everyone's
obsessed with themselves so the whole
thing is like like the mirroring thing
for example is just like because you're
you're doing the same thing that the
other person is doing or saying similar
words that the other person had just
used your that person's feeling like
their egos getting fed because it's like
oh like you're following my lead oh
you're lead yeah yeah yeah - like any
response in this room that's would be
like yeah no wait no especially with
what Joseph yeah with Joe is crazy catch
you guys anyway so this guy's name let
me show you a photo of this liar
I see people looks like a professional
soccer player cuz I got a certain look
and usually Liars do when you say some
bizarre [ __ ]
what is the look just long and skinny Oh
liar oh they look tone and like a
thicker layer look at that [ __ ] liar
soccer soccer is that e-news face death
we'll never played soccer you know there
even is teeth that's will never play it
sock my first question would be what
happened to your body that's not even
his coke dude what a liar like I feel
like you should did he lose his job you
do what well he left all his credibility
he needs to start from scratch baby how
do you start from scratch ok erase it my
memory and then no I mean like he gets
fired and now he has to work it work it
all back up but there's also these
serial killers are still happening he's
like yeah you're doing good but go back
to the bottom well then all the guys try
to get them I wouldn't be able to trust
needs me like Sherlock Holmes you know
the police are like no no we don't want
your help but help them anyways yeah
like it like he already lost his
credibility like completely but he was
right and it helped people for a little
bit but
what else is he gonna lie about probably
he huge has got lucky or whatever cuz
he's like a fanatic in it yeah but he
got lucky we did you hire him Nadine but
it's helping people but the real
question how many people you know like
how much help you actually I'm sure it
loved it but did it hurt anybody
yeah that's the thing I don't think so
so let's say you're hiring this guy
right you get his resume and it says FBI
how come nobody [ __ ] call to say hey
how was he isn't him cuz it's in France
I wouldn't give a [ __ ] you got a pals
international fees little phone calls
they should have got free roaming
charges free international calls
unlimited baby
switch to Verizon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]